the bad thing to me is it's completely
insane misspelled you know especially
like the type I guess there's a specific
type of bat that they say it came from
and that bat typically carries four
different types of coronaviruses that
we've been exposed to over the decades
but apparently this new form of virus
somehow the bats are immune to it and I
was watching something on I believe it
was vice it was a video that they posted
some of the researchers are trying to
find out why the bats don't get sick
from coronavirus and if we can apply
that research to humans
somehow have you heard anything about
that the best is the host in this
example and the virus doesn't affect the
bat it just lays in the host and that is
the reservoir of the virus so then we
get into that area where we've never
been before we cut down the trees the
jungles whatever and then we start
interacting with the virus and it repels
the humans and that's Nature's Way of
balancing things out that's really
interesting but they can't jump from
animal to animal so you have the horse
Spanish flu in the late 1800s that came
before the human Spanish flu and it
jumps from horses to birds to humans and
we think you know Wow how could
something jump from an animal through
human really right right we think was
something special but we're actually
which is the same you know material
animals are made up so yeah these
viruses the bacteria they've been around
for millennia billions and billions of
years they look at humans it's just a
little dot on their time frame they have
all kinds of sneaky ways of survival and
they're in a constant battle against us
but if they wipe us all out they can't
continue so they have to assimilate with
the host population at some point and
the pandemics you know Trump just said
we've beat the virus with America's open
for business by Easter but if you saw
what he just said there today
he he's in the dream world because
pandemics can go for years
Spanish flu was over a year and they
come in waves and it was a second it was
the second wave of the Spanish flu that
caused the most harm I mean it's a
hundred percent fatal for pregnant women
people 220 240 with the most robust
robust immune systems died the most
because and they were the healthiest
people because their immune systems
reacted so well that people drowned in
their own mucus
[Laughter]